there's no one person who is the ideal  Mentor you don't want to be me you don't  want to be Jordan Peterson you don't  want to be Oprah they have parts of  their I have parts of my life that you  don't want the whole point is to take  different pieces from different people  to make the best you for me I want to be  a Visionary like Steve Jobs that's why  he's on my wall and I want to be a  father like my father was that's why  he's on my wall I don't want to be a  father like Steve Jobs was and I don't  want to be a Visionary like my dad  because they're not so you're taking  different people and different things  from them to help you become the best  you